Welcome back, it's time for Drew's News,
your swish swash of the good news mouthwash.
And with me at the desk, there's no man more minty fresh,
Rossy Ross Matthews.
Aw, hi. Hi everybody.
(audience clapping)
All right, first step, Ross,
this story just freaked me out.
So, are you ready for it?
(Ross laughing) Yes.
All right. Ross, I'm gonna put all of us on the spot.
We need to talk about sheets. How often do you wash yours?
I go about a week to 10 days.
All right, well everybody buckle up.
What?
Hold onto your headboard, Matthews,
because we have the answer from a doctor.
Cosmopolitan reports dermatologists say
that you should be washing your sheets once a week.
How many people, raise your hands,
wash your sheets once a week?
Ish, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, this one is where it gets dark.
You're supposed to wash your,
I'm like drooling I'm so anxious,
you're supposed to wash your pillow cases every day.
(Ross gagging)
Oh no. You think, get ready.
We shed 30,000 to 40,000 skin cells a day,
many of them in the bed.
And you know who loves to chow down on skin cells?
No, I don't wanna know.
Dust mites!
(Ross gagging)
Uh-huh! And your mattress becomes a bed buffet.
I mean, I literally,
I think I'm literally getting like itchy,
like allergic reactions telling this story.
(audience laughing)
I'm not kidding.
I know.
It's like, I, this isn't like theatrics.
I understand.
I am, I like need a Benadryl.
Dust mites, uh, disgusting.
It's something I don't wanna think about.
I know they exist, but I don't want to acknowledge them,
like bills or calories, I don't wanna know about you.
That's my, gross.
Okay, Ross, your story.
All right. Next story.
PureWow reports painting your bathroom a certain color
can increase your home's value by $5,000.
What?
What?.
Yes, uh-huh.
So, everyone guess in your mind what color it is.
Think about it.
$5,000?
Just by painting a room, yes.
And the color is pale sky blue. Yeah.
Zillow did an analysis
and people were willing to spend 1.5% more on a home
if the bathroom was pale sky blue.
Yeah. That's a crazy fact.
Are any of your bathrooms this color?
No.
Me either.
Well, what about your bedrooms?
They say dark moody colors
increase the value of your house too for a moody bedroom.
What?!
But for kitchens, stay away from mint green.
They say the kitchen, that is the kitchen kiss of death.
It can de-value your home by $2,000.
Wow.
I know.
Well, I'm really surprised
to hear about the mint green kitchens.
'Cause in a lot of decor magazines,
you see a lot of green kitchen.
I guess, but I guess you have to,
when you're selling a house,
think about what the customer wants.
You know what I mean?
When you, so if your....
Blue bathrooms, not green kitchens.
And dark bedrooms, what's that all about?
Well, you know what that's about, girl.
You know what that's about?
Oh. I forgot what that's about.
(Ross laughing)
Well, people might hate mint green kitchens,
but I know one mint that we can all get behind, a Thin Mint.
Oh, my God, I love a Thin Mint cookie.
By the way,
while I've calmed my itch situation down,
I've also been smelling something incredible.
And it's this. It's Girl Scout cookie season, Ross.
Oh, thank God. You know what I call Thin Mints?
What?
Double chin mints.
(all laughing)
Because I will go to town on a Thin Mint.
Oh, my God, I love that so much.
I'm so glad so I could just hear that.
Well, guess what everybody?
It's time for Food News.
Oh, yeah!
(audience clapping and cheering)
So, this just in, the Girl Scouts just got a new cookie.
CNN reveals that the newest star in the lineup
is the Adventureful cookie.
Well, this cookie is inspired by the Brownies
and it has salted caramel and is a brownie.
So, the Brownies got a brownie. Let's try it.
You had me at salted caramel.
You ready?
Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
(audience laughing)
Oh,
my
God.
(audience clapping)
(Ross stuttering) Yeah, right? I can't even, there's.
Okay, go away for a minute.
I can't, don't point the camera at me.
Oh, my God. I am not kidding.
Who here likes Girl Scout cookies?
(audience cheering)
Okay, I planned all day for that cookie.
I really adjusted my lunch, the whole thing,
so I could have that cookie.
And that was good.
That's the best date I've been on in a long time. I tell ya.
That is so phenomenal
that I feel bad eating it in front of everybody
because all I want them to have
is the experience I just add.
I know, I know.
But you can go to girlscouts.org and buy your cookies
and support the Girl Scouts today.
And order this one. This one is so delish.
Don't mess around. Get the Adventurefuls.
This is, this might be my new favorite.
Yeah.
Wait until you try these.
I wish, gosh darn it, why don't we have more of them?
All right, we'll be right back to play Pop Quiz.
I'm itching, I'm eating.
Pop Quiz!
Nicole!
(upbeat music)